monastir aller bonjour merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france n'est
pas la première salve de sanctions
américaines contre l'iran il ya eu le
pétrole et les banques beaucoup d'autres
secteurs impactés quels sont les
domaines visés cette fois ci et quelles
conséquences pour le peuple iranien est
principalement ce sont les domaines
d'armement qui sont visés en ce moment
c'est à dire que l'iran la république
islamique pour attirer l'attention de
vos spectateurs
je fais la différence entre la
république islamique et l'iran l'iran
c'est le peuple iranien et la république
islamique c'est l'état qui gouverne ce
pays
alors les nouvelles sanctions
américaines visent l'achat des armes au
mans ça va nuire à la république
islamique
mais pas au peuple iranien parce que lui
et valiant qui vit aujourd'hui son
quotidien que ses dirigeants puissent
acheter des armes ou pas il préfère
plutôt pas c'est à dire que les armes
pour lui ça ne change absolument rien
dans son quotidien
donc il faut pas exagérer en disant que
les américains méchants américains sont
en train de nuire au poc
c'est vrai que depuis début de cette
histoire les iraniens souffrent
énormément les iraniens sur nos martyrs
je suis bien placé deux rouleaux
confirmé c'est ma famille qui est visé
ils souffrent chaque membre de ma
famille souffre en ce moment mais je
vous le dis laissons les nouvelles
sanctions aujourd'hui ne vise que les
armements en plus le père y était déjà
économiquement dans un état désastreux
donc les sanctions qui sont revenus au
niveau il ya deux ans n'a visé qu'un
pays qui était déjà en souffrance parce
que les dirigeants de la république
islamique n'arrive pas à gouverner son
pays pour correctement ce qui fait au
jour d'aujourd'hui les iraniens l'homme
par les airs aniane normaux qui vivent
leur quotidien n'ont rien contre les
américains parce que ils culpabilisent
plus ils critiquent davantage leurs
propres dirigeants que les dirigeants
des puissances extérieures des
puissances étrangères
et quelles conséquences allant d'un
point de vue international ssi
niveau intérieur il va pas y avoir
beaucoup de changements ce qu'on a
entendu un pékin moscou bruxelles qui
condamne mais au delà même de condamner
quelle marge de manoeuvre justement
est-ce qu'ils vont suivre washington ou
pas écouté la question n'en fait doit
être opposée si vous me permettez
autrement et vous voyez il faut pas
regarder les choses de cette façon qu'il
y à des méchants américains d'un côté et
des gentils pays la chine la russie et
les européens de l'autre côté ça serait
vraiment la non connaissance totale des
rapports internationaux que d'analyser
la situation de cette façon en fait la
véritable histoire c'est autre chose
là l'histoire c'est que les américains
veulent imposer leur hégémonie sur la
planète et il y à des pays il y à des
puissances qui résistent comme la chine
comme la russie et comme les européens
et malheureusement pour les iraniens
malheureusement pour le peuple iranien
ils sont pris en otage entre deux camps
de groupes de puissance à côté les
américains donc d'autres côté les autres
personnes personne ne fait attention aux
intérêts du papier rien n'y a personne
ne demande la vie du papier ralliant la
seule chose qu'on pense la chose la
seule chose qu'on dise c'est laid on
répète systématiquement les paroles de
jabba dea diplôme ministre des affaires
étrangères iranien
on répète les propos des dirigeants
iraniens sans jamais demander ce que les
iraniens disent donc votre reportage les
paroles de la jeune femme correspond à
la volonté des iraniens
ce que cette femme avec ce que cette
jeune femme a dit correspondent à 100% à
ce que j'entends systématiquement de la
bouche et iraniens les iraniens sont un
peuple paisible
ils ne veulent la guerre avec personne
avec aucun pays et ils ne comprennent
pas pourquoi depuis 42 ans
leurs dirigeants sont systématiquement
en situation conflictuelle avec les
puissances du monde à commencer par les
américains et les espagnols et ne
comprennent pas et donc cette jeune
femme a parfaitement bien reflété la
volonté de la paix le
souhaits des iraniens pour avoir la paix
et malheureusement aujourd'hui les
iraniens sont devenu le bouc émissaire
des grandes puissances d'une guerre
internationale entre deux groupes de
puissance et malheureux dire deux mots
aussi est-ce que je me permets de vous
pouvez pas ce qu'il y'a eu président
iranien qui a réagi pour washington la
pression la politique de pression
maximale s'est transformé en isolement
maximale sur les modes hassan rohani
tout à l'heure qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque
il aurait nationalisme diplomatique ou
unilatéralisme martiale pour washington
évidemment vous parlez d et pas de
méchant ou gentil non dans cette affaire
mais par rapport au peuple israélien
justement au peuple iranien justement
cette annonce d'un san juan y avait qu
est ce qu elle vous évoque
écoutez ça fait rire vous savez pourquoi
parce que ça fait quarante deux ans
qu'on entend ce genre de paroles
grandiloquente et contre les américains
on va faire ceux ci ont vengé on va leur
donner une bonne leçon
mais en fait tu as un gros ni le
président iranien il peut se permettre
de parler de cette façon parce que les
intérêts nationaux des iraniens nous
rendre pas ne rentre pas en ligne de
compte des dirigeants de ce pays
ils s'en foutent royalement les enfants
vivent à l'étranger dans les pays
européens
ils sont richissimes ils ont volé
l'argent de son corps et son richissime
donc innover le soucis du quotidien
ils n'ont pas le souci de l'individu qui
vit à téhéran dans les villes iraniennes
et qui n'a pas de quoi manger qu'il a
dont les enfants ont faim donc ils
peuvent se permettre de se moquer des
américains vous savez la force des
dirigeants iraniens
c'est dans le respect des intérêts
nationaux dans leurs peuples et depuis à
chaque fois qu'il ya des problèmes
ils réagissent de la même façon au lieu
de résoudre le problème au lieu de
diriger le pays vers la paix merci merci
magasin shir ali d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
docteur en sociologie politique
enseignante à sciences po spécialiste de
l'iran donc et auteur du livre le
mystère
de l'iran contemporain